i also want to invite you to uh
subscribe
free to the david pakman show subreddit
with now more than
30 000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed
at davidpakman.com reddit this morning i
saw some interesting posts including
one that asked so do anti-vaxxers think
that their friends will still hang out
with them
one of the easiest steps you can take to
reduce covet risk
is to not see anti-vaxxed people that
you might know
even though i am now vaccinated and
fairly comfortable returning to more
normal activities i will definitely
avoid anyone that is anti-backs
says this viewer do anti-vaxxers think
people won't avoid them we have been
avoiding risky activities for a year so
do they think people will just start
hanging out with them again maybe
friends deciding not to see anti-vaxxers
will nudge them towards getting the
vaccine i think there will be that to a
degree
i think it depends on what part of the
country you're in uh but
at i know that much to the chagrin of
those who are now suddenly want medical
privacy
i regularly am saying to people are you
vaccinated i was invited to something a
couple of weeks ago and i said is
everybody vaccinated and i was told
uh yes everybody is and i said great
okay i'll be there
and um when i was invited to a different
thing
three weeks ago and i was told well you
know of the four couples
two are not vaccinated uh i said yeah
it's not for me i'm just i'm not doing
indoor stuff with unvaccinated people
right now it just doesn't doesn't really
make sense even though i am
vaccinated outdoor i will do i think
that will be an issue and i think that's
a really good uh
thing in if it influences more people
into getting vaccinated for sure
um another user says the party of free
speech
looks to cancel liz cheney for speaking
against trump
yeah this is i'm glad that this is is
being um
exposed the incredible double standard
on cancellation and free speech the side
that has been claiming to be all about
free speech and
claiming to be all about not canceling
people
is now trying to cancel liz cheney
they're trying to get her
uh removed from her leadership posts
they're trying to get her off of
committees they want her
primaried and removed because she had
the audacity to think for herself on
impeachment
and she had the audacity to um
say what should be really
uncontroversial which is hey
joe biden won and the election wasn't
rigged and of course it's much of this
free speech for us but not for you
except it depends unless you disagree
but
if we like it then of course we'll
defend it it's always been a pathetic
hypocrisy
it should be pointed out and the liz
cheney cancellation attempts are only
the latest example
and then lastly uh a user claiming that
tucker carlson inspired assaults have
started
so i want to be clear that there has
been a horrible
attack in new york city by an individual
who came up to another and said take off
that mask
and beat them and we have no particular
reason to think
that the ass uh the attacker was
inspired by tucker carlson's recent
rants
saying if you see people outside wearing
a mask tell them take the mask off
we have no reason to think that but the
tucker carlson
statements the tucker carlson rants
about uh being against masks
are the type of thing that we often
describe as stochastic
terrorism in this case it's not
terrorism it's stochastic
anti-massacre ism or something like that
where um if you have a large enough
audience some people will hear you say
demand the masks be taken off and they
will do it and they
they will even take it to the next level
there's certainly not going to be any
liability for tucker carlson i'm not
suggesting that nor am i suggesting that
there should be it really raises some
very
uh dangerous questions uh if if just
saying that then would be linked back to
tucker and tucker could get arrested
because someone told someone assaulted
someone else over
a mask that's not what i'm suggesting
but
there is no question that given the size
of tucker's audience
it will have an impact and whether this
has any connection to tucker or not we
will never know
but there are you know with great power
comes great responsibility i don't know
who said that that might have been
uh i don't know who said it it might be
from spider-man actually i don't know
but um there there is a responsibility
to understand what would be the
follow-on effects from the things that
you say when you have a platform i try
to think about that every day
and it certainly will have an impact
join the discussion on the david pakman
show subreddit
davidpakman.com reddit